understand and really respect the fact
that relationships should be treasured
not used because particularly in the
online business World there is a lot of
the using going on I'm going to get
close to this person because I want to
be on their podcast or I want to get
close to this person because I want them
to promote my book or my course to their
100,000 email list or whatever right I
call a massive amount of BS on those
types of individuals like I I am friends
with some of the most influential names
in the online business space I have
never ever asked them to do anything for
me and that is still the reason why when
I'm in town I get invites to go and
sleep in their house or in their
apartments or the reason why they pick
me up from the airport when I land like
these are the kind of relationships that
I truly
treasure